you know I'm talking about Koval 19
there's no easier way yeah if you can't
name that song then shame on you you're
not American okay uh I usually I've
gotten used to in doing the morning show
I've gotten used to sort of hitting news
and it comes a little bit more quickly
and I'm kind of wired and tired and I
realized I wouldn't be able to talk
about this until tonight when we're
doing the the live live stream of the
press briefing which should be a really
good one because Donald Trump does
signed an executive order on immigration
so stay tuned follow me on Twitter for
that but this is really important this
just came out and it is it is driving me
up a wall I want to know if your
opinions change or how they've changed
throughout this whole kind of pandemic
not kind of I mean you know yeah kind of
fend of it because these new numbers I
want to see if you can I'm not in the
studio so forgive me I'm almost Samantha
B or Jimmy Kimmel level hackery here
hopefully you can see that from USC not
exactly a bastion of conservatism and
the County of Los Angeles Public Health
they did some antibody testing there now
right where they took a sample of the
the County and did some uh some testing
to see who maybe wouldn't have tested
positive for the virus but at some point
had had it and they found a two point
eight to five point six of the county's
adult population had anybody's for
coronavirus which means between two
hundred and twenty to four hundred and
forty thousand people in that County uh
have had the virus okay again pardon me
I'm not I'm not doing the Chris Cuomo
thing I'm like oh I just came from the
gym it happens this is just I live I
live like a homeless person so that
means that it's twenty eight to fifty
five times higher the amount of
Americans who have the virus that we
initially thought okay guests are still
the same they're at six hundred so that
means in Los Angeles County the
mortality rate at its absolute highest
now is zero point two five percent now
let's just take the sort of
middle-of-the-road numbers right look I
don't know if you can see this right now
but now I have to hold up I have to hold
up my own arm here because I think very
weak in the shoulder I can't do the
dolph lundgren lifting rocky up so um if
you were to just take the average let's
say
I don't know 300 something thousand and
be very conservative in our estimate in
Italy it was 95 to 98 percent depending
on what sources you use of people who
died from coronavirus had pre-existing
conditions were over the age of 80 I
think in New York it was 90 something
percent of people who were over the age
of I believe 70 or had pre-existing
conditions you know what let's just call
it 80 so the 600 deaths in Los Angeles
County let's say that really really low
and 80% of the people who make up those
deaths all deaf matter of course I want
to make that really clear okay I care
about all that's right NSA that would
mean that the mortality rate for an
average aged or middle-aged or above
middle-aged of average health American
is 0.02 percent 0.02 percent and again
all lives lost matter of course but it
seems right now this fundamentally
changes how we view this disease it
seems like if the disease a virus that
is far more communicable than the
average flu but but potentially not all
that much more deadly particularly for
younger people healthy people and there
is the possibility that it could be in
some cases less deadly and it is just
amazing to me I have to say how
disheartening has been to see people who
we thought were kind of more
conservatives sounding the alarm and
being willing to give up their freedom
so quickly listen i-i've always said
this could get way it could still get
worse potentially could come back right
next year but this idea that this is
something that is worth shutting down
destroying people's life you know what
all businesses are essential to the
people who rely on them to make a living
well you know boys I can't I can't
what do you mean I can't go to work I
can't put food on the table for my
family it's not essential the elitism to
me knows no bounds with this and now
you're seeing to a lot of it you know
they've been talking about wanting to
save local public
nations this is the big thing now
they're saying local news needs to be
saved but they can't actually start I'm
hearing my wife yelling at Betty because
she she just ate a fish oil tablet and
that'll be fun having to - see how that
comes out later hopefully she doesn't
show I was talking about something here
I'm pretty wired and tired and doing two
shows a day I'm not going to lie to you
but it is it is remarkable to me that we
are talking about shutting down I
people's livelihoods that may never
reopen that's a reality 30-something
percent of retail businesses that aren't
groceries they don't believe that
they'll reopen after this and going back
to the idea of local media you know
they've been saying that we need to
bailout local media that's really
important well here's the thing it turns
out that most local media is actually
owned by the giant national media or
international media conglomerates and so
they actually don't qualify and so now
there's some legislation being pushed to
bailout that you know what on a second
why do we bailout the Schenectady
Register before the franchisee owner of
a Shake Shack how about how about this
local media once you start actually
reporting the facts reporting the news
and you know if you're going to be we're
talking about advocacy journalism which
is really all journalism nowadays how
about you start advocating for the
American public that they should be able
to go back to work now that we know the
mortality rates now that we know that
this disease is this virus is far more
widespread than we thought and has a far
lower mortality than we thought you do
that then maybe then maybe you can get
your beak wet with a little bit of
Abella but if you want to tell everyone
else to shut down their businesses is
non-essential I can't think of anything
less essential than the Scottsdale
Herald okay I don't think that you
deserve a bailout when there are other
people who don't want to bail out they
just want to go back to work and be
aren't receiving one and you know what
this is not only do I think there's not
going to be a new normal and I bet you
this is going to be a question tonight
at the presser there should not be a new
normal this to me really just showcases
a complete lack of understanding as to
how the economy works and what a
business owner go
through you know when they say we need a
new normal I think it was a question at
a recent press press briefing with
Donald Trump you know sports stadiums
that have seating for a hundred thousand
now they only have 60,000 wait what
come again stupid do you honestly think
that business owners let's not even take
a sports arena but I think UT when my
brother went I'm not mistaken someone
can comment below hama when he used to
go to UT it was ninety five thousand
seats and i think they upgraded it to
over a hundred thousand seats so let's
say it's a hundred thousands put it you
know make it an even number nice even
hundred thousand because i like doing
math when it's more simple do you really
think that they can sustain those costs
at almost half capacity and only sixty
thousand people let's let's scale that
back
what about restaurants what about the
italian restaurant down the block that
has seating capacity for two hundred the
new normal is just to shut them out of
business just well now your new normal
is actually you're only going to see one
hundred but listen that's when we make
all of our revenue during peak hours at
dinner time we need that to keep the
doors open
just so that the the employer here the
business owner can eat let alone the
employees do people just think that
every single business owner is sitting
back on a mountain of cash that you can
stand there from your high tower that
you you you hope obviously is is bailed
out by the federal government as you
write your from your from your blog but
it's a legacy paper but let's be honest
it's really a blog most local news blogs
their blogs that don't really matter are
relatively inconsequential for a lot of
them and the real journalism can be done
by people on twitter or people with
youtube pages do you really think that
you can have their business and then not
have a word to say about it you know
what let's take it even further let's
say they go along with us let's say you
somehow managed to have some kind of
authoritarian regime come in and say hey
the new normal is all of you business
owners all of you businesses that have a
certain capacity for clientele
water parks sports venues sports bars
pubs restaurants
take your pick i don't know how some
blues any place that that that would
require more than ten people to
congregate in order to do business let's
say that you get some kind of regime
comes in and says you know what you have
to be you have to operate a half-caf
capacity and somehow you managed to do
it what do you think is gonna happen to
the rest of the American public the
prices of those goods and services are
going to double you think it's tough to
go to the movie theaters now try it when
they can only fit in half the capacity
you think it's tough to go to a to go to
a ballgame now wait till you see the
prices of the hotdogs and Cracker Jack
boxes when they have to cut their
capacity in half
you think restaurant bright you think
it's expensive to eat out now well guess
what the Schenectady Gazette doesn't
really care about you all that much
because um they got a bailout so now
you're going to be able to go out and
eat less and what do you think that'll
do for the economy at large what do you
think it'll do for the global economy to
try and force people's hands to try and
panic people into shame based on what we
are seeing now again from USC okay
USC a death rate mortality rate at the
absolute highest end possible 0.25 call
0.26%
I'm feeling generous today and at the
more likely end for average age
Americans is 0.02 percent let's split it
down them
hero point one to tell the American
public to take this on the chin well you
don't have to is something that I hope
people do not soon forget they were
hoping that people would not soon forget
this going into election so they can lay
it at the feet of Trump I am hoping that
people do not soon forget the media
malpractice and I'm really looking
forward to tonight's press briefing it
should be absolutely lit so follow me on
Twitter or just tune in here on YouTube
I think they started around 6:00 p.m.
Eastern but you know president Trump's a
busy man so we don't know when he'll
shoe up shoe up show he's a shoo-in to
show up again I'm very wired and tired
doing two shows a day look at the Grey's
not quite Cuomo he is a shoe in the show
of I meant to say shoe and show up and
then I flipped the two and what I
actually just did in saying that in my
brain
I split the is I actually just wide I
had no intention of saying Xuan I was
just embarrassed that I said shoo up